so you and Rob had the top floor of that
of that we had yeah and jacuzzi on the
roof with the jacuzzi on the roof it was
a pretty Bachelor Patty yeah I got taken
back to that apartment with a jacuzzi on
the roof and you were like I guess you
were in the place you're like well this
isn't going to be a long-term thing
like it's like jacuzzi on the roof is
not a red flag it's like you could
afford a Jacuzzi
you know like wow
you were like mac and Dennis creating a
hot tub onto a roof
right now if we have a quick midlife
crisis let's get an apartment and with a
jacuzzi on the roof be a lot sadder now
we'd be going into to soak the things
that hurt you know
right it was all different motivations
on that roof everything
yeah yeah Rob's in a nice bath
[Applause]
[Music]